you going to Facebook and you see the
likes and you see this validation and
it's a Tabata Tabata tabular tambour tap
and now attention spans are shortening
you see young people who can't function
outside of their phones they have
difficulty maintaining real
relationships combine that with hardcore
unbelievably stimulating pornography and
the real life experience doesn't live up
question of the day before I move into
the segment what's your opinion on porn
harmless or normal corrosive dangerous
and from all angles I'm one of your
using moral legislative and personally
what are your experiences with it have
they bet you consider them struggles let
me know this is a topic that people have
a lot of differing opinions a lot of
heated opinions yeah because many aren't
heat so the context here this is um
it sort of started as a mean this whole
by the way if you have children they
probably shouldn't be here for the
segment we're gonna talk about this
frankly and really try not to make a
bunch of dick jokes so I try real hard
really ya know not too hard we will try
it there with great vigor
that's no difficult elegance yes due
diligence because I get smart so no not
November is what it was called so that
was kind of a meme and it was baseless
idea that people weren't going to watch
pornography or masturbate throughout the
month of November so survives a joke
hidden crime went up by a thousand
percent but more and more young people
at it are in deciding especially since
they've been doing this that that porn
is bad for them that it doesn't work for
them they don't want to be watching porn
some of them feel as though it's a real
problem not necessarily everybody so
I'll get to my opinion in a second but
the media entertainment industrial
complex they've been trying to go on the
offensive for those who don't know and
they've been trying to give into it for
a long time but more so recently that
porn and masturbation is actually good
for them even going so far as to tie it
in as they always do with something that
they weren't supportive they necessarily
don't like they just go you know we're
going to tie no not November to the far
right clinical psychologist dr. David
leg
has a theory about why these young men
are so angry they're not strangling
their peppe's across the alt-right
movement leaders are telling young men
not to masturbate religious groups
harangue the public about the dangers of
porn on the body and on the mind but the
evidence just doesn't pan out common
sense might say that men who watch a lot
of porn might have trouble getting it up
at this research found precisely the
opposite instead of inhibiting arousal
men who watched porn actually got more
erections and that result was maintained
with as much as 25 hours of porn
watching a week you a sexually explicit
material in order to get sexually
interested in order to have that what do
you mean you watch porn out of boredom
okay just been ridiculously bored and
you're just like so much I got the air
just watch the porn who cares be
whatever you want to be
how does more allow you to be whatever
you want it doesn't does that mean if I
doesn't see it if I just believe it is
he in the pod against pornography so
let's get a psychology today by the way
they've even been pushing it their
advice for developing they actually say
porn is good for developing more sexual
integrity because it makes people less
religious and more positive went toward
homosexuality so let's be really clear
Psychology Today would sooner have you
watch Japanese tentacle gangbang than
read the book of Matthew now let me be
clear that's an I disagree only on a
personal level but let's look at the
facts as they relate to the
ever-changing world of porn I think it's
very important that we define what we're
talking about here yeah because this is
where you'll see a lot of different
opinions and I think a lot of sort of
boomers older folks are kind of out to
lunch we're not talking about a nudie
magazine right no under someone's bed or
buried out in the flesh and the words to
go out there with a box of tissues you
know if the seasons permit have no idea
assuming that they're in the northern
hemisphere the southern hemisphere
doesn't exist because there's this flap
anyway I think it's a cube but lots of
flatness so we need to address it we're
talking not about a magazine or even a
video we're talking about a tab in a
cabinet a drawer tap tap tap tap tap or
not
yeah and that's very different and we
did an interview conducted an interview
with Gary Wilson of your brain on porn a
long time ago so let me be clear
porn is far more ubiquitous than in our
parents our grandparents okay it's
become so pervasive now that studies
show one in 10 porn users are under 10
years old insane
think about that for a second when you
take the top 2 porn sites together they
account almost 6 billion monthly views
that's more than Twitter Wikipedia or
Instagram Wow yeah so this is important
because we need to acknowledge how many
people are using it how frequently they
are using it and the kind of
ramifications that it could have again
this is very different before we even
knew about the idea of addiction of
social media I talked about this with
Kerry Wilson now they've talked about
the guy who played by Andrew Garfield at
Facebook who said like we didn't realize
it we were effectively developing an
addiction platform for young kids will
you combine that with the greatest
dopamine release or was that barring
drugs that we know in the human body and
that's sex so you combine the tab and a
tab and a tab and the violation of
expectations and people are addicted to
their phones only you add bodily fluids
that's what we're dealing with right now
so it's a little bit different than what
we're talking about someone looking
through you know this year's wishlist
catalog hoping for a nipple by the way I
found one in 1998 worth it that's why
she's gonna sing for you she Hulk was
the car carnage is super now when I
looked at it under my brother's bunk bed
I would get very comfortable so
considering the prevalence it is
important to look at the mounting
evidence that shows there definitely
some negative psychological
ramifications and I want to talk about
this because a lot of people out there
struggle with it and say well what what
can we do and the truth is people are
far more ashamed I think out there now
to discuss their struggles with porn
than they are to just talk about or
praise porn yeah yeah and we can't be
flippant about it if you have this many
people you one in ten or under 10 years
old
you'll be like any other public health
concern if you find out that you know
one in ten people who eat cheese I don't
know get Sarge you better you start
looking at Jesus I thought the Kerrygold
at Trader Joe's was good because was
grass-fed from New Zealand cows turns
out no I was incorrect yeah Irish cows I
should get that right otherwise there'll
be a little snow piles in the
on YouTube great resource your brain on
porn.com at first let me address this on
the outset yes there are studies out
there that show apparent benefits to
porn that's what people can they can
make the argument but surprise surprise
they're based on subjective
self-reported data come to me
differently that's pro porn and anti
porn it's like the healthcare statistics
they go on a second how how do you say
that we have better health care in the
United States and people in other
countries don't think so well if you
look at these subjective health care
rankings and these are just globally
ranked based on people's personal
satisfaction with their health care it
rates us right between Slovenia and Cuba
yeah then there was the UK world health
study it was 11 countries ranked the
United States was ranked 11 the UK was
ranked number one despite us having
higher survival of cancer rates I think
you're twice more as likely to die from
breast cancer so subjective reporting is
not an accurate measurement for the
effects of pornography people like porn
and people who watch porn and want to
watch more porn of course are going to
say it's been great for me yeah exactly
it's like making policy by polls like
Bernie Sanders does I don't know what do
people think well let's do that so
apparently Bob Geldof a big heroin some
of the objective studies though as it
relates to to porn much more likely to
make people feel depressed it
desensitizes people evidence points to
the fact that it pushes them to more and
more taboo content often involving
violence combining violence and and
sexual arousal as a result it can make
sex less enjoyable in real life it can
lead to problems like low libido lack of
interest in sex erectile dysfunction in
men
let me prevent what the statistic isn't
about self reporting that I like naked
ladies and that's not what we're saying
young men's erectile dysfunction rates
used to be around 2 or 5 percent yeah
after the creation of free streaming
hardcore pornography numbers are now
between 14 to 35 percent that's almost a
thousand percent increase that's what we
call statistically significant Japan
it's gotten so bad
36 percent of young men are not
interested in having sex at all I don't
think it's the porn on that one though
well it's just kidding no it is also
very weird stuff that happened in Japan
it's a weird place
the horny teen archetype American Pie
yeah compare that to 36% of young man in
Japan no no no no I just reported in a
computer I have a second what about if
you want to have what if you want to
have sex with the real lady in real life
no no no no just Anita USB yeah the USB
P this is like a tournament leave their
porn apparently is early exposure by the
way since we're talking about 1 in 10
young Pete one in 10 of porn users are
under the age of 10 early exposure can
increase young people's chances of
acting violently towards others risky
sexual behavior this shouldn't come as a
surprise no STDs okay so objectively
porn can also something people need to
know and I think a lot of people
experience this is why I want to know
what your subjective experiences have
been but objectively I can harm
relationships divorce rates double when
people are watching porn once when one
spouse is watching porn married couples
have less sex which it doesn't seem like
we're treading new ground talking about
this here but a lot of people don't talk
about as you see one stone in young
turks just watch the porn
what's the matter what what if what if
it is something particularly this sort
of this this almost mmm like meta porn
that we have now with these tabs and
hardcore pornography and highlight reels
yeah
whatever it does have negative
ramifications right what if all of this
data adds up and you go home in a second
how irresponsible is it to say just
watch porn and by the way yes I'm a
hypocrite before you want of course I've
seen porn of course everyone in this
room is a hypocrite I want to be clear
about that we'll come back to that
afterwards by the way please do hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
because subscriptions don't really mean
a whole lot new video every day at 8
o'clock Eastern 9 o'clock Eastern and of
course subscribe at mug club that's the
only way that we can continue to make
these videos because we've been he
monetized for a long time to go back to
this idea you know there's something
called the violation of expectations
yeah and I talked about this with Gary
Wilson he was talking about how this is
why the internet is very addictive to a
lot of people or social media right you
want to search something it could be I
don't know you're looking for a skillet
what's the best way to season the
skillet
and you type in a search and you find
more information than you could read in
a lifetime about seasoning skillet yeah
right I'm gonna have to tap in a tab in
the tap or same thing you want to see
what your friends are up to and you go
into Facebook and you see the likes and
you see this validation and it's at a
bit of to have it at 10 or 10 per tab
and now attention spans are shortening
you see young people who can't function
outside of their phones they have
difficulty maintaining real
relationships let's combine that and by
the way this is this is admittedly a
problem from people who created these
social media platforms combine that with
hardcore unbelievably stimulating
pornography it was always a concern
before social media but it's very very
different now because young people are
creating a neural pathway to get to
sexual pleasure and by the way before
they actually have sex before they
engage in any kind of consensual sex in
a loving relationship they could have
experienced this neural pathway and duck
walk down this path thousands of times
yeah before ever actually having a real
life experience and the real-life
experience doesn't live up how many
people were addicted to newspapers or
magazines yeah hell yes I got I got my
Sunday paper it didn't happen didn't
happen you weren't you weren't hiding
from your wife in the bedroom in the
dark with the funnies so we need to
address what it is that we are talking
about we need to fine it and it is a
very different animal right now
pornography and I think this comes this
does come full circle
I'm obviously more libertarian I think
that people can do whatever they want to
do personally with their own bodies in
the privacy of their own home but we are
talking about pornography in the
legislation there have been many
attempts to regulate the distribution of
porn to minors right so I do think this
is important because you do need to see
where people line up on both sides of
the aisle there are many laws right
against adults actively showing porn to
minors right but there were there have
been many attempts to require actual age
verification for porno sites and again
everyone here probably knows it says are
you 21 yes what criminal mastermind
could possibly fool that system that's
so hard to break they can enter in your
birthday I don't know into a crime but
half the time if I'm just going like a
cigar web site or something I just put
on any random birthday just go out and
all five 1487 I know I'm good
you don't think a twelve-year-old can
figure that out right so anytime there's
an actual attempt for real laws
regarding verification to view online
porn at a federal level they've all been
overturned yeah in the courts so think
about this for a second again this is
why I just think it's irresponsible to
tell people just go watch porn who cares
well no one is advocating that kids can
get into our rated movies by themselves
no but anyone can just open up their
phone click yep 21 and then whatever of
the most depraved hardcore porn you can
imagine and by the way
hardcore porn that none of us could have
imagined when we were 16 18 years old
pre Internet is available to them and if
we talk about you know drag queen
storytime with kids and transitioning
children and people rightfully get upset
about that because we want to protect
the most vulnerable and innocent among
us then we do have to talk about what
porn could potentially be doing to our
kids no one is saying that you should be
able to sell porn to an eight-year-old
that's the illegal but for some reason
keeping an age-appropriate as far as
online content it always gets knocked
down what do you were a kid you walked
through those Cowboys swinging doors at
Blockbuster they couldn't grab you by
the collar fast enough and pull you out
of it exactly but now there's no one to
do that and I know what a dress that's
to I think is important this idea of
hypocrisy because the left will often
point to hypocrites on the right yeah
and it is with ben shapiro when he
talked about pornography yep i'm a
hypocrite
everyone here is a hypocrite but i think
we need to recognize the difference
between systemic hypocrisy and hypocrisy
in vice right you see the left they
often point to republican they go oh
look he's a hypocrite he he believes a
immoral Christian family values but we
found out that he was on what was that
what a sh ly Madison or we found out
that he was addicted to porn or you know
or look this guy who are you George W
Bush who are you to tell people that
they shouldn't be abusing alcohol are
drugs you did coke one time yeah we get
used to do drugs moral hard that's why
someone is advocating against certain
vices yeah as we understand that it's
corrosive and these are in Vice by its
very nature means that it's tempting to
everybody and its inherit and I don't
think there's any more inherent carnal
desire than that to procreate naked
ladies look good
so wanna be for everyone is a hypocrite
on the right and on the left sure but I
do things of the left points to
hypocracy on the right more so as it
deals with morality and vice and issues
of conscience that we all struggle with
that's not the same as
Al Gore advocating for green climate
policy right advocating for carbon
offsets and you not being able to drive
an SUV SUV but flying around the world
in a private jet in three homes that use
more power than you use in two decades
time that's not the same as hey listen I
think pornography is really bad oh look
there's a naked lady of course I want to
watch it versus I think that you're
killing the planet but I'm going to fly
around and a Learjet there's a
difference a difference in hypocrisy
found in Vice every single person at
some point in their life is a hypocrite
as it deals with these issues that is
not the same as people who are
proactively hypocritical and they make a
hypocritical decision beforehand out of
convenience
no one gets pulled by the lure you no
one's born right in here when we're born
as soon as we know that we're men no
one's like that as soon as we think
therefore I am I need a private jet it's
not the same thing and this is something
- everyone's going to point in laughs
right we see this a lot with with people
who are here any people did with Jordan
Peterson right this is Jordan Pederson
wants to help people but his wife was
dying of cancer and he found himself
addicted to anti-anxiety drugs anyone
not does anyone I find that incredibly
reasonable yeah doesn't it it's a good
thing by the way he went out and sought
help exam which is in his book which is
what he tells you to do exactly he has
always talked about everybody loved
going for get getting help yeah that is
not the same as what we're talking about
this is people who are just pointing at
the those who enter the arena saying
haha
you didn't make you didn't make a
perfect high jump you missed your flaws
burry flop when they sit in the stands
and don't attempt to do it right that's
the difference been that versus banning
high jumps we're not talking about
banning high jumps but they do want to
point out hypocrisy in ways that they
are hypocritical as well yeah because
everyone on the left is just a
supercritical everyone who says porn is
good well you can say they're not a
hypocrite because they're just lying
about it preemptively yeah what's allow
for the possibility that a lot of you
could probably casually dabble and porn
and not have a problem there are
probably lots of people whether if you
don't think there's anything morally
wrong with pornography and I know that a
lot of you don't
there are probably quite a few people
out there who could occasionally enjoy
pornography and not see any negative
manifestations as it relates to their
life but this is this is where you're
gonna see how upset people get by me
just suggesting this but if there are
people out there who don't feel that way
people out there who do struggle with
pornography
start from no not November people out
there who say you know what I watch porn
and I don't want to and they find it
difficult they find the pole hard to
deal with and maybe it's verging on an
addiction you know what there are a lot
of resources out there there's your
brain on porn we'll have some links in
the description and I would like you to
comment I'd like this this place below
to be a I don't want to use the word
safe space because now that's been
ruined but slightly like triggered is an
actual psychological term like for
someone who is in war if the legit but a
safe spacial people can talk about
pornography today in the comments
section send me your tweets what have
your struggles been in people who've
overcome it help people out there
provide some resources right now and
let's some people other some other
people in on how they can find help now
watch you're going to see some people
claim gonna hate that this right here is
propaganda all I'm saying is people out
there who find themselves under the
spell of pornography and want to break
the chains okay we'll try and offer some
help to you to other people who have a
profit that's fine
move on to the next comment section I
hope you enjoyed this clip if you don't
these are the ABCs of me baby you can
just click Next video and put it in
double speed of course search doesn't
necessarily work subscriptions
notifications don't necessarily work
just bookmark this page check and we do
a new video every single day except for
Sunday and if you don't want this
content to disappear join my club at
Ladder with credit comm slash Mudd Club
it's only $69 if you're student veteran
or active military and if you don't you
know listen I I don't want to say that
you're hell bound but it it doesn't look
good for you